Єгор Олійник ледве вижив. Він воює за Україну
проти російських окупантів - завжди на передовій.
Потім він наступає на міну й отримує важке поранення.
Хотів застрелити себе, але перебила мене потім така думка: батьки… Ні.
Це ж лише нога. Коліно моє, ходити зможу.
Він ще живий, може ходити і стріляти.
Місяцями його приводили до тями.
Можливість знову битися допомогла йому впоратися з гнівом.
Вийшов - відстрілявся. Все. Так вже спокійно. Розслабився.
Так він використовує свій досвід.
На полігоні на сході України.
Вони щойно повернулися з фронту. Зараз це навчання.
Єгору двадцять років, але тут він один із найдосвідченіших солдатів.
Ще до війни - у 18 років - пішов добровольцем.
29 вересня. Це ми відбили позицію.
Це тільки-тільки була захоплена позиція. Підбита техніка.
Трішечки, знаєте, емоції просто зашкалювали...
Найцікавіше просто в окопі лежить - це російський "визволитель".
Незабаром після цього Єгор зі своїм підрозділом знову
займає російську позицію.
Коли він йде по канаві, щоб перевірити ситуацію, це і сталося...
Це, мабуть, "пелюстка" була. Касети порозкидали і я наступив.
Упав, не зрозумів що до чого. Дивлюсь на ногу, а там нема.
Просто її немає. Дивлюся: рука перебита.
Єгора евакуювали. Поранену ногу доводиться ампутувати.
Він провів сім місяців спочатку в лікарні, а потім на реабілітації.
Він має навчитися з цим жити.
Його родина протестує, але він уже вирішив. Єгор хоче повернутися на фронт.
Борг є в мене перед державою.
Я був у відпустці, а друзі мої сидять вдома, бухають, гуляють.
Я їм кажу: так, а чого ви? Я повернувся, а ви? Та ми оце думаємо-думаємо…
Дуже багато втратив друзів. Дуже багато через це їхнє ставлення.
Єгор більше не спілкується з ними.
Він очікував більшого. Більшої жертовності, більшого патріотизму.
Через п'ять тижнів. Приблизно 2000 кілометрів на північний захід.
Ліллехаммер на півдні Норвегії.
Тут Єгор лікується вже місяць. Завдяки приватній норвезькій ініціативі,
яка опікується пораненими українськими бійцями.
Тут він отримує новий протез.
З цим протезом стопа більше згинається. Я можу…
Тут більше амортизація і в мене не йде удар в кістку.
Тобто в мене все чудово.
Новий протез має полегшити його життя - також як і солдата на полі бою.
Сьогодні він отримує для цього додаткове забезпечення.
- Привіт.
- Привіт, ласкаво просимо!
- Там має кляцнути чи як?
- Так, має увійти до кінця.
- Вже чи ще ні?
О, все. Є.
Якось так більш впевнено нога стала.
Але коли ось так роблю, наче він спадає трішки.
Протезистка Ганне Крістін Гарстадгауґен стикається
з кількома викликами одночасно.
Він молодий і має бути з друзями, зі своєю дівчиною,
а не йти на війну.
Важко ще й тому, що ми не знаємо, що потрібно бійцю з протезом.
Я не знаю, чи це спрацює, якщо щось зламається, наприклад.
Те, що Єгор може бути тут, у Норвегії - заслуга деяких
працівників цієї клініки. Місцеві лікарі мають великий досвід
реабілітації людей з ампутаціями.
Тому запропонували взяти українських військових.
Один з ініціаторів – керівник клініки Ойстейн Торп.
Коли я бачу, як він біжить в окопах…
Я робив це, але тільки на тренуваннях
і в безпечному середовищі.
Торп - колишній військовий, і вважає своїм обов'язком допомогти.
Люди дуже пишаються тим, що ми це робимо.
Не тому, що ми не пишаємося усім медичним сервісом,
який вони надають, але ми хочемо зробити внесок у щось більше,
ніж просто допомогти звичайному норвезькому пацієнту,
який живе в безпечному та здоровому суспільстві.
Це невеликий внесок, але ми пишаємося ним.
Загалом Єгор тут на п’ять тижнів - разом із Дмитром Соболевським
- теж військовим з ампутацією після вибуху міни.
Попри спокій і віддаленість від поля бою
повністю тут не "вимкнешся".
Це ніби два різних світи.
Там - війна, а тут - мир, все спокійно, все тихо.
А там навпаки - такий хаос...
Дні в клініці насичені. З силовими тренуваннями та гімнастикою.
- Не болить нічого?
- Ні-ні, все чудове, все добре.
Почервоніння - це нормально, я тільки протез вдягнув.
Тиск був. Протез новий.
Ірена Золберґ перекладає. Вона головна лікарка.
Виїхала з України тридцять років тому.
Тепер вона особисто опікується українцями.
- Дмитре, як ти? Скаржся. Які проблеми з новим протезом?
- Одразу він мені, наче, підійшов. А приїхали сюди, то вже боліло.
- Еллен каже, що вона не рекомендує, щоб ти сам крутив ці протези.
Дмитро відчуває труднощі з новим протезом.
Український мені підігнали і він підходить мені більше.
Я можу в ньому цілий день ходити, на велосипеді їздити.
Тобто інтенсивно працювати. Навіть на мішку можу працювати.
На цьому я так не зможу. Але тут стопа краща. Нічого. Я це виправлю.
Лікарі кажуть, що може допомогти ще одна операція.
Але поки у 39-річного військового інші плани.
У Норвегії обидва військових можуть набратися сил для майбутнього.
Дмитро не буде продовжувати воювати, збирається
піти з армії та шукати, чим займатися.
Він не може повернутися до своєї роботи в сталеливарній промисловості,
оскільки виробництво зупинено через війну. Його майбутнє невизначене.
Єгор, який уперше за кордоном, каже, що Норвегія
надихнула його і він хоче частіше подорожувати в майбутньому.
Але зараз його знову тягне на фронт…
У свої 20 років він майже нічого не вміє, окрім як воювати.
Взагалі вже після цього справді не боюся.
В принципі те, що пройшов… Вже нічого страшного не побачу.
Тільки якщо щось друге не відірве. Руку. Ногу.
Тоді, може, вже замислюся.
Коли вже другий раз сюди приїде.
Тоді я, може, вже замислюся.
Отак буде сидіти і буде цокотіти.
Вони жартують, коли йдеться про серйозні речі. Особливо Єгор.
Мене теж, буває, тягне туди. Є хлопці, які зі мною були з першого дня,
коли ми призвалися і вони зараз ще воюють.
Слава Богу, що вони цілі. Таке відчуття після поранення
десь пару місяців кожен день хотілося повернутися туди.
Помститися в основному, так?
Так. А потім минає час і вже адаптуєшся в цьому житті – в цивільному.
В мене є ще син, якого потрібно виростити.
Перед тим, як він повернеться, потрібно пройти останній огляд.
Медсестру Туріл та лікарку Ірину особливо вразила
наполегливість українських пацієнтів.
Інші наші пацієнти бачать їх і надихаються.
Ви дізнаєтеся від них про все, що можна зробити з протезом.
Це додатковий мотиваційний стимул для працівників.
Коли я виїхала з України і жила в Естонії, Латвії і потім тут,
звісно, цього менталітету українського мені не вистачало.
І з приїздом цим хлопців, звісно, життя ожило по-новому.
Їхні стосунки особливі…
Наче, як вдома, під контролем. Наче, як батьки, за тобою дивляться:
те не можна, там те, те... Як в сім’ї, начебто. Все добре. Все чудово.
Відпустити їх в Україну для працівників лікарні дуже складно.
Важко стримати сльози, не плакати. Я знаю, що хлопці їдуть назад
в країну, в якій війна. І ми ще не знаємо, як закінчиться ця війна.
Дуже важко. У мене немає слів.
Давайте про щось приємне поговоримо.
Вони повернуться. Дмитро - до рідного міста, а Єгор - до військової частини.
Він міг би залишитися тут, будувати нове життя, вчитися і працювати.
Але його тягне до України і в окопи до своїх побратимів.
Попри всі жертви і, можливо, саме через це.